if you had no fear if there was no fear
what story would you tell right now on
camera you can say on camera it's your
camera you are now working on something
called the Travis technique for
autobiographical storytelling the Travis
technique for autobiographical
storyteller
yes that's a long title what is it about
what is it about well it's it's about
autobiographical storytelling obviously
and where it comes from I have to go
back and give you a little history of
this because you made it sound like
we're just starting this this has been
going on for about 30 years
and about 30 years ago through
circumstance I got involved with helping
develop and directing a one-person show
with Paul link which became time flies
when you're alive thus that story which
became a stage play it was the story of
Paul's wife who got breast cancer and
eventually died from breast cancer and
it was the story of that whole journey
that he went on with his wife and his
children while she was fighting breast
cancer and without going into more
detail because there's a lot of detail
too it's a very powerful stories and
very powerful love stories of it's a
very sad story it's a very tragic story
it's a very heroic story and Paul was a
friend of mine and I knew Francesca and
when he said he wanted to write a play
because he and I and another friend of
ours Denis Redfield had created several
plays together that we had done he said
he wanted to create a play about their
life together and her death at home
because she refused to go to hospitals
and stuff like that and I remember
saying to him this was only a week after
she died I remember saying to him fine
okay but let's talk about it later let's
talk about it after the memorial service
the memorial service for Francesca was
going to be in a few days it was
actually at John Ritter's home in
Brentwood we were all there was a
beautiful out
the back lawn you could see the
mountains and a lot of white balloons
you can imagine the white piano people
played music people read poetry is very
sad but it's all this tribute to
Francesca and then Paul was gonna speak
last and Paul with their one-year-old
child she had a child while she was
fighting cancer which is a big part of
the story but that Rosie that
one-year-old child in his arm he got up
and started to talk and he's this first
thing he says he's I want to tell you
about my best friend and within a few
minutes he had everybody there laughing
as he was telling this story and I'm
watching him and I'm going oh my god
this is amazing
and afterwards I talked to him and I
said Paul we're gonna do the play but
not the play you thought you were gonna
do he said what do you mean
I said you we're not going to do this
play of all these characters I said it
has to be a one-man show it has to be
just you telling your story I wanted to
take what I had seen there and put that
essence of Paul and his vulnerability
and his openness and his honesty in this
transparency on stage because I said
that's the only way this is gonna work
we worked on it for about a year we did
a lot of research and we even talked to
Spalding Gray and we'd do it a lot of
things of development this is the first
time I'd ever had done this after that
was done I said to myself and it was
very successful ran for a year in Los
Angeles sold out at the Tiffany theater
was a sort of a weird situation but I
said I'm done I said I can't do this
again it's exhausting working at one
with one person on one show but it was
it was a beautiful experience until I
was at an acting class and I heard
another monologue this man got up and he
told the story about when his mother he
did this monologue about from some play
I thought about his mother picking up
after school taking him 350 miles away
from their hometown putting him in a
motel and leaving him
at the age of 10 for the summer and he
told this to it I went oh my god I said
after I said Shane where you know where
that story come from I'm the winner
what's that from it's amazing because I
thought it was from a script he says
that's from my life and I remembered
that feeling at that moment going oh my
god I've got another one
now this kept happening I kept getting
people were started coming to me and we
did that that show which was called no
place like home which was all about
child abuse that's why she took him
there to save him from her the father
who was intent on killing the son she
saved his life so that was a whole show
about child abuse and then came a Bronx
Tale which I developed with the Chazz
Palminteri and that became it so
suddenly all these shows became big hits
and people said coming to me but it
wasn't that the fact that people coming
to me what my tendency I have to tell
you a little story when I was a young
boy I was very good at fixing things
taking things apart and fixing things I
loved doing that and my father had an
old watch pocket watch which didn't work
and I asked him if I could take it if it
wasn't valuable at all and I asked him
if I could take it apart but he said
sure so I took the whole thing apart and
put because I was curious to figure out
how it worked and I got it all back
together again it still didn't work but
it was all back together again the
reason I tell you that is this is the
way my mind works I'm less interested in
the final product of what I create than
I am in how its created so I did a lot
of research while I was developing all
these one person shows up what how does
this process really work what are the
techniques that work why did this work
in this with this show and not with this
show of life all of these things and
from that long period of time which
started back in the early 90s a long
period of time up until to now we're
still doing this exploring this whole
aspect of autobiographical storytelling
why is it so powerful and what are all
the tools and the techniques that you
can use in the telling of any story that
would change and alter and enhance or
mold the story in the way you want to so
that has led to but again back in the
90s someone asked me to teach a workshop
on what I was doing this is like after
I'd had several very successful shows
and I said I couldn't I said I can't I
said it's just one on one I worked with
the actor and then we worked together we
developed the show that's it and then
that person did something which is
totally unforgivable offered me a lot of
money to teach the workshop and I went
no then maybe I can do it so I agreed to
do it and I started a workshop and
that's when I started to realize I can
teach this there is a lot of stuff I do
know and so this has become now this
workshop which at that time was called
the solo workshop because it was mostly
for solo performers now it is morphed
into being called the write your life
workshop because it's not for solo and
it's for everybody's for solo performers
the writers memoirist screenwriters any
any storyteller so we have storytellers
from all over the world who want to take
this workshop because it's so powerful
not because they want interesting not
because they want to learn how to tell
autobiographical stories they want to
learn the basics and this sort of the
core and the foundation of storytelling
because when when like screenwriters
take this course they suddenly they're
screenwriting improves so it's a
foundation so when it says the Travis
technique for autobiographical
storytelling this Rachel life is the
foundation of everything else and I
teach not just the waiting but the
directing and acting and working with
that and all comes out of that so when
people come to study with us the first
thing they do is write on a biographical
story and again go through that process
it's like learning the scales before you
start to try to play classical music or
something else what if someone says well
I'm not a writer and I'm not I'm not
planning on doing a one-woman show why
would I need to learn how to tell my own
story where opportunities that we have
this in our daily lives we don't even
realize it in our daily life though I'm
assuming this person that you're
throwing at me is a writer or just just
just an average maybe they're an
insurance adjuster all insurances and
they say what convinced me why should I
take a class to learn how to tell my
personal story and I would go back this
is going back to some of our first
question some of your first questions I
would say to that person okay you're an
insurance adjuster you're working with
people and clients and all the time yeah
when's the last time you told one of
them a personal story once a lot and why
were you telling that story and did you
get the result that you wanted did you
communicate what you really wanted to
and Eve were you even aware of what you
are trying to communicate and if you
were aware of what you're trying to
communicate do you know there were
probably several a dozen different ways
you could have told that story to get
the result you wanted in other words I'm
just saying that in your work and your
life you frequently tell a personal
story you go to a family reunion and
suddenly people are telling stories and
you have a story to tell do you want to
tell it consciously or unconsciously do
you want to be aware mindful of what
you're doing and how you want to impact
other people how you want to be seen
what you want them to think so we're all
the interesting thing about storytelling
people people say well I'm a storyteller
I'm a screenwriter I'm a story tell him
a storyteller who isn't who doesn't tell
stories my
serious belief with a children before
they can speak
all that little those little noises
they're making oh yeah yeah whatever
they're telling the story in their mind
they're telling a story they are
communicating something eventually they
get language and eventually they get
words and then stories come out so even
if you if you have a little three year
olds or four year olds you wouldn't who
can be very verbal two year olds gonna
be very just listen to them their
stories just start tumbling out of them
it's a huge part of who we are in fact I
think you know the storytelling gun is
right up there with breathing
we do it all the time unconsciously we
need it I'm not even knowing why we
don't get to go through the day we
reminding ourselves to breathe we just
do it we don't go through say oh I think
I should tell a story we just do it and
then there's another part of like right
your life which is very important which
is do you know how to listen to a story
do you know how to hear a story
and someone someone's telling you a
story can you listen listen for the
story and listen for what's really going
on can you see beyond what they're
really saying to see deeper into the
story so there's that that aspect of it
too so that insurance sales person could
benefit enormously what if someone says
well how can I tell people about myself
but I don't want to tell them certain
things then don't tell them those
certain things in fact don't pick those
stories pighead pick a different story
yeah there are there are a lot of people
who are afraid to tell stories because
they were afraid of what they're going
to reveal but then this is a big aspect
a part of the Rachel life process is we
ask and we don't ask for the answers to
this question we ask everybody like I
could ask you Karen all right go ahead
if you had no fear okay
was no fear what story would you tell
right now on camera you can say on
camera it's your camera if there was no
fear I know a few you know a few okay
absolutely yeah yeah even even that's a
you know in the workshop me even that
even people in the workshops thinking
about the important thing of that
question is not the story you come up
with importantly about that question is
the realization that my fear of that
story is what's stopping me the fear is
the important part not the story and
then this has happened many many times
in the workshops one little thing about
the right July 4 workshop which I'm very
proud I was back in 2001 I was asked to
teach it in Hawaii and I taught a
weekend workshop there and then
eventually became two weekends because
it became so popular - consecutive
weekends
this is where I met Elsa because she
would she was a student back in 2002 but
and that workshop went on for 16 years
up into 2015 anyway I went on for 16
years and the thing is there were times
when we would bring it up like you know
if you had no fear what story would you
tell people go oh yeah a lot of people
who took the workshop would take it
every year which was great they would
come back every year because they were
not because again getting back to your
other question not because they're gonna
do a one-person show not because they're
gonna write the stories they did it
because they liked the process of
exploring themselves through these their
stories and hearing their friends
explore themselves and expose themselves
through their stories and many times we
would bring up that question if you had
no fear what would you what story would
you tell and people go yeah I know and
we asked him to write it down they'd
write it down we don't ask him to share
it and many times two or three years
later someone would tell his story they
would say that was the story I wrote
down years ago that I was afraid to tell
there we go Wow
something happens now this is a very
important part of autobiographical story
to him in one show that I did this is
where it became really clear this is the
one on child abuse and Shane McCabe who
was brilliant performer told me this
story a little story within the big
story and the little story was about him
living in his bedroom where he was
forced to sleep in the closet and
because his his house was built by his
father and it wasn't built that well
there were a lot of openings and places
and he's in the closet and this little
squirrel showed up in the closet and
over a long period of weeks and weeks
and weeks he started to develop a
relationship with this squirrel okay and
it's a beautiful story and how the
squirrel eventually eat out of his hand
to how the squirrel when he could get
sneaked out of the closet and sleep in
the bed the squirrel would sleep with
him wherever you they would sleep
together now has a very tragic ending
which I'm not going to tell you horrible
ending but as Shane is telling me this
story he said like I'm gonna tell you a
story but it's not going in the show he
says I wanted to tell you the story
about chipper because he kept mentioning
chipper and I didn't know who chipper
was so he tells me about chipper the
squirrel this horrendous story not me
being a storyteller and maybe in a
director I hear that story go all this
is good this has to go in the show and
he's going it's not going in the show
I'm not gonna tell that story and I
could see why because he was so
devastated he can barely hold himself
together while it was telling that and
you don't want that onstage and he
doesn't want that and we kept working on
the show developing and developing every
once in a while chipper would come up I
would mention chipper he wouldn't
mention chipper and then one day he said
to me
maybe the chippers story should go in
the show I said really I said and I
would ask him to tell me again and he
would tell me the story again and then
we tried we said okay let's put it in
we'll rehearse it we'll try it and we
did and he kept telling it and telling
it telling it the key thing was I
remember on opening night or at the
Tiffany theater in Los Angeles he's
opening it in front of 100 strangers and
he's on stage telling that story and
he's fine he's told he's has it all
under control and what became clear to
me was these stories that are so
traumatic and so awful that we are so
afraid if we tell them probably afraid
that we're gonna die we'll never recover
we'll lose all self-esteem oh well
whatever whatever's gonna happen it's
just going to be horrendous or people
are gonna find out about it and and I
can't live with that
whatever the fears are if you keep
telling the story and this is my way of
looking at it it's not that the fears go
away but the power shift is a ship the
story is here and you're here this story
has power over you and it keeps and it
keeps it suppressed but if you keep
telling this story what happens is it
shifts and eventually you have power
over the story same story same dramatic
intent same trauma everything but you
have power over the story and Elsa and I
have seen this so many times where
people have suddenly found somewhere the
courage or the strength to tell
something that they thought they could
never tell and so this process is also a
healing process not intended to not
designed to do that but it does it
you